- Product name, Mango Creamy Soda,
parentheses, carbonated drink.
(pouring liquid sound)
(upbeat music)
- Peering down the bottle
at what color this is
I'm like a little suspect of it.
- Look at the milky white.
- Little cloudy.
- Can we say the thing
we think it looks like?
- It looks like (bleep).
- Good luck.
- It tastes like mango juice.
- It tastes just like a bunch of
melted Haribo gummies in dirty water.
- I would 100% drink this soda.
- I would definitely buy this at the store
because it's so tiny and I would love
to just carry it around
and have people comment.
(lid pops)
- Oh, cool!
- Oh my God!
- (screams) What?
- What a surprise.
- Oh, it packs a punch.
- It's like liquid Smarties.
- It does like a little bit of Red Bull.
- It's an entirely new taste to me.
- I like it.
- It's okay.
(laughing)
- Cool, I see Hello Kitty
and I know Hello Kitty.
- There's a paragraph of instructions
on how to open it.
- There's some down here too.
- Oh, this punches.
(cracking)
- Place opener on top of a Ramune bottle
and press down firmly with your palm.
(cracking)
- Oh my God!
- Am I doing it right?
At this point, lunch is
over, my lunch break is over.
- Alright, that's not bad.
- It's super sugary.
(sound of disgust)
- Yeah, that's the worst one yet.
- Really?
- I really like it, actually
it reminds me of the
frozen ice pops.
- This tastes like Jones Soda to me.
- I would agree with that.
- I think, like, mixing this with alcohol
at a party would be fun.
- I noticed you just poured more of this.
You went back for seconds.
- I think there's a chemical in this
that's controlling my brain more than me.
(lid popping)
- What is that?
- It kinda smells like rotting fruit.
- What does that smell like?
- (laughing) What is that smell?
- This soda's angry at me.
- Nope, nope.
(laughing)
I'm against this taste.
- Oh goddammit.
- Wow, that's very unpleasant.
- Kind of a sour,
(snapping) sparkling cider.
- Yeah, this makes my
tongue wanna leave my mouth.
- Yeah.
- Like apple puree for babies.
- Yes!
That's exactly what it is!
- It's like a baby food.
- It's baby food soda.
- [Voiceover] I have arrived,
I shall take one tiny beer.
- Are you enjoying the
giant football game?
Throw me one of that tiny six-pack.
- Here, one tiny beer for you.
- One tiny beer.
(laughs)